i recently got
for the first time ever
got covered
um
how did i go so long
without finally so i'm all vaccinated
and everything like that and so i got uh
because i think he he mentioned it
publicly so i can mention it but i won't
mention anybody else involved but
hanging out we've all got you and got
covered and the interesting thing about
maybe you can comment about this so i
was only sick for like a half a day i
got a fever of like 104 i just went up
and then crashed and then i was
now maybe i'm just uh seeing the silver
lining of everything but
afterwards
uh
i have like a greater clarity about the
world
you just think it's greater clarity
maybe maybe i just it was so
uh maybe so intensely
the
mind fog kind of thing for such a short
amount of time but the people were
involved were also reporting this it's
kind of interesting it's like uh because
i i do know
like the immune system
uh is involved with the brain in very
interesting ways so like the human mind
also incorporates all these other it's
not just the
it's it's not just the nervous system
and i i just wonder because everyone
always says no not like everyone always
says like hope it does all these bad
things or whatever the disease is or
whatever the virus but i wonder like
i hate to be a steven pinker on this but
like i wonder what the benefits of
certain diseases are if you're
like what is there some like uh again
don't want to romanticize it but if your
system goes to some kind of hardship and
you come out on the other end i wonder
sometimes if there's a greater um maybe
killed off a bunch of neurons that i
didn't need anyway and they were
actually getting in the way there were
the hater neurons well that
you know there are mechanisms for what
the potential mechanisms for what you're
talking about
there are uh there's actually been a
fair bit of research on
post covered
neurological
function and actually my wife michelle
manjei who's at stanford she's done a
lot of this work akiko iwasaki yale has
done a lot of this
but what what they found is that
there's a loss of myelin this is the
coating of those long-range projections
that go from one part of the brain to
another myelin is this sort of insulator
that coats these long-range projections
and makes the impulses go faster and
more reliably
there's altered
uh
function of the myelin producing cells
and altered myelin in
the case of covert they've looked in
both mouse and human brains
and
but of course it could be very
idiosyncratic
many people have cognitive problems
postcoded you're definitely aware of
that so many people report this
persistent brain fog inability to
function
but it depends on where the inflammation
was you know maybe the people who have
dysfunction
postcoded they had a global effect
maybe you
lost some of these projections that were
restraining you in some way and and
these plausibly exist and it's known
that there are
cell populations in the prefrontal
cortex that actively restrain
deeper structures from expressing what
they do
and it's it's theoretically possible
that you had a lucky
uh somebody has to get lucky right
somebody has to get lucky
why not
you